It puts itself correctly in the step but as soon
as there is 1 change in the pace I lose everything.
How to do it?
There is nothing more normal in 1st time or with
1 young horse to get this famous put on the hand.
The horse that stands up,
or at least comes to round its neck and bring its
field brake closer to the vertical in slow paces,
at a walk in particular,
or even more with ease when stopping.
Because that's how we'll be able to teach him to give in to pressure.
And as soon as we ask him to go in the brighter paces,
the higher paces,
the trot or the gallop,
everything deteriorates.
1 little bit.
Simply because your horse still lacks flexibility and relaxation.
In reality,
coming to ask him to stand up will stretch his entire top line.
This is what appeared with this famous notion of tension,
tension of the top line,
the back which goes up under the effect of the neck
which rounds out and the engagement of the hindquarters.
All this will pull a little bit on his back,
exactly like us.
When we try to make the big,
it shoots,
it shoots more,
we go down At a certain moment.
It's not too bearable at the moment because we're not flexible enough yet.
We'll want to get back together.
And for that,
there is only one solution,
to continue to teach him to give in to pressure so that little by
little he finds his comfort while developing his longitudinal flexibility.
And to help you do so,
I invite you to take up the TDS challenge.
To have 1 horse that is softer and lighter,
simply click on the link you will find in the bio or description of this video.